[Musik]
ein kleiner ort im kreis olpe in
nordrhein westfalen
wir sind unterwegs zu maik wernicke
hallo hier sind
[Musik]
das ist ja mal eine ungewöhnliche
situation
mike ist 28 und studiert
politikwissenschaften jahrelang der
computerspielsüchtig heute hat er seinen
konsum im griff sagt er er spielt nur
noch gelegentlich aber immer noch gerne
davon auf dem dach landete rechts von
uns
wieviel zeit war das denn so zur
hochzeit wie viel haben sie darin
investiert also zu der ganz schlimmen
zeit wo ich arbeitslos war da waren es
16 stunden am tag vielleicht sogar noch
an manchen tagen vielleicht sogar noch
mehr man vergisst dann auch manchmal zu
schlafen auf dem bett zu gehen zu essen
weil es socken anhalt wichtiger ist und
im netz hat wo ich noch eine
arbeitsstelle hatte da waren es trotzdem
dann auch acht bis zehn stunden nebenbei
plus eben die arbeit und schlafen und
freundinnen und man muss ja auch noch
mal essen und einkaufen so was alles das
musste ich alles irgendwie da
unterbringen aber ich wollte halt ist
level halten oder auch einfach gar nicht
unbedingt ums level zu halten einfach
nur weil ich vielleicht gar nicht anders
konnte
also ein fulltime-job
mit 7 bekommt mike seinen ersten game
boy mit zwölf den ersten pc schnell ist
er angefixt von der digitalen spielewelt
kritisch wurde es als ich mit 19
ausgezogen bin das hat so ein bisschen
auch mit ihm spielen zu tun meine mama
hat irgendwann neu geheiratet und meinen
stiefvater dann und ich habe mich mit
dem häufiger in die haare gekriegt wir
haben uns sogar tatsächlich ein paar mal
auf die nase gehauen
eben weil er zum beispiel mehr das
internet abstellen wollte und wenn ich
kann ja schlecht aus neun spiele spielen
wenn ich kein internet haben
mike macht noch seien aber die
ausbildung zum industriekaufmann bricht
er ab sein einziger lebensinhalt ab da
ist das zocken
[Musik]
diese glücksgefühle ausgeschüttet werden
wir mein level up hat oder sowas ist
geräusch so man hat so erfolge dann
spielen das ist schon etwas
was man vielleicht dann auch im echten
leben nicht hat das ersetzt das echte
leben natürlich
[Musik]
2500 stunden seiner lebenszeit hat mike
allein in das kostenlose online
rollenspiel neverwinter investiert ein
anreiz der ihn am spielen hält es gibt
kein ende immer wieder kommen neue
updates
mike schafft den absprung erst mit hilfe
einer mehrmonatigen therapie er ist mit
19 jahren in die sucht gerutscht andere
erwischt es schon viel früher
[Musik]
2020 haben fast 700.000 kinder und
jugendliche in deutschland riskant oder
pathologisch games gespielt
betroffen sind vor allem jungs
das universitätsklinikum
hamburg-eppendorf hier im zentrum für
suchtfragen des kindes- und jugendalters
werden jugendliche behandelt die schwer
abhängig sind von alkohol und drogen und
von digitalen medien der 13 jährige
joshua ist seit sieben wochen patient in
der tagesklinik er ist
computerspielsüchtig
joshua heißt eigentlich anders seine
eltern haben den dreharbeiten zu
bestimmt mit seiner betreuerin bespricht
er die aktuelle woche
weißt du noch was wir als wochen ziel
dieser verorten
rechtzeitig aufstehen die medien um 22
uhr weglegen und um 22 uhr 30 im bett
liegen
wer das gestern klappt ja ich wollte
noch kurz dran aber dann dachte ich mir
nicht auch sie jetzt einfach aus
allein hier an der uniklinik hamburg
werden jedes jahr 400 jugendliche
behandelt die von digitalen medien
abhängig sind professor rainer thomasius
leitet das suchtzentrum wir sehen dass
die jugendlichen immer jünger werden
wenn sie in behandlung kommen vor zehn
jahren waren die jugendlichen 16 bis 18
an übergang zum erwachsenenalter und wir
kommen doch immer häufiger mit 12 13
jährigen jetzt in therapeutische
kontakte
laut jüngsten zahlen der dak gesundheit
verbringen jugendliche derzeit werktags
im schnitt 109 minuten mit
computerspielen das sind 31 prozent mehr
als vor der korona pandemie
seit die investiert wird in
computerspiele und soziale foren ist
einer von mehreren risikofaktoren eine
sucht zu entwickeln bei solchen wo
selbstunsicherheit ängstlichkeit
depressivität im hintergrund steht kann
die gefahr einer suchtentwicklung größer
sein als bei residenten jugendliche es
gibt klare kriterien dafür ob jemand
computerspielsüchtig ist habe ich keine
kontrolle mehr über mein spiel verhalten
rücken andere lebensinhalte in den
hintergrund spiele ich immer weiter
trotz negativer konsequenzen
joshua konnte all diese fragen mit ja
beantworten kann es mal beschreiben wie
du dich gefühlt hast wenn du gespielt
hast also es war unterschiedlich ich
wollte eigentlich nur erfolg haben ich
habe die zeit oft vergessen und dann hat
meine mutter ist bemerkt und mich auch
öfters darauf angesprochen dass sich
ausmachen soll und ich habe nicht darauf
gehört
joshua ist während der korona pandemie
in die sucht gerutscht zu hause sorgt
sein verhalten immer wieder für streit
es ist seine mutter die ihn dazu
gedrängt eine therapie zu machen
hast du das spiel kontrolliert oder das
spiel dich kontrolliert
das spiel hat er mich kontrolliert ich
war dann sauer geschrien oder so es hat
mich zu der person gemacht die ich
eigentlich gar nicht bin
zwölf wochen lang wird joshua die
tagesklinik besuchen er will lernen
wieder einen normalen
tag zu führen mit schule hobbys und
festen schlafenszeiten und er will es
schaffen seinen umgang mit den games zu
kontrollieren die chancen dass er es
schafft stehen gut 70 prozent der
jugendlichen die hier wegen
computerspielsucht behandelt werden
gelingt es vom exzessiven konsum
wegzukommen
[Musik]
computerspiele sind längst fester
bestandteil im leben vieler kinder und
jugendlicher
wir laden drei teenager ein warum
spielen sie was macht den reiz aus
sie wollen mit uns über ihren spiele
konsum nur sprechen wenn sie nicht
erkannt werden sie haben angst als games
junkies abgestempelt zu werden deshalb
setzen sie masken auf
[Musik]
die drei stehen stellvertretend für ihre
generation
sie zocken fast täglich am pc auf der
konsole und am smartphone sie hätten ihr
spielverhalten im griff sagen sie
[Musik]
wenn ich aus der schule komme oder aus
einem stressigen tag kann ich bei diesen
computerspielen abschalten und dann
nichts mehr denken sondern nur noch mich
aufs spiel konzentrieren
man kann sich halt so fühlen als würde
man halt der charakter selber sein man
fühlt sich gut man vergisst alle anderen
sorgen oder so und schaltet einfach von
der realität ab das fühlt sich meistens
extrem gut an
72 5 prozent also knapp drei viertel der
12 bis 17 jährigen spielen regelmäßig
computerspiele unter den jungen sind es
sogar 90 prozent
[Musik]
jeder freund den ich hab spielt also das
heißt so ein zwei stunden und tag immer
eigentlich auch jeder den ich kenne
spielt in meiner altersklasse
sie zocken shooter spiele wie fortnight
open world spiele wie gta oder
smartphone games wie clash of clans die
spieleindustrie sorgt ständig für
nachschub immer wieder kommen neue titel
auf den markt
die games branche ist ein riesiger
wirtschaftszweig sie macht inzwischen
mehr umsatz als die kino und musik
industrie zusammen und sie wächst
[Musik]
2009 10 hat die spielebranche weltweit
152 milliarden us-dollar umgesetzt
2020 waren es bereits 175 milliarden
viele spielehersteller konkurrieren um
die aufmerksamkeit der gamer erfolgreich
sind die die es schaffen die nutzer ins
spiel zu finden
früher musste man ein videospiel erst
kaufen um es spielen zu können
heute dominieren so genannte free to
play games den markt das sind spiele die
man sich umsonst herunterladen kann zum
beispiel auf die konsole oder aufs
smartphone
nun habe ich ein spiel das kann ich mir
kostenlos runterladen wie verdienst der
spielehersteller den geld damit dass es
gibt zwei möglichkeiten zum einen bleibt
die finanzierung durch werbung das heißt
in den kostenlosen spielen gibt es ganz
oft irgendwelche werbeeinblendungen oder
man bekommt irgendwelche boni wenn man
sich werbung anschaut aber der deutlich
größere anteil der findet durch in app
käufe statt das heißt dadurch finanziert
sich das spiel tatsächlich und das sind
dann wie gesagt zum beispiel
extra outfits oder extra leben oder
irgendwelche boni für das spiel den
erwerb solcher extras in spielen nennt
man in game käufe 2020 haben sie rund 70
prozent des gesamten branchenumsatzes
ausgemacht hier liegt aktuell das größte
potenzial für das große geschäft
wir sind unterwegs zu ulrike volpers
wissenschaftsjournalistin und mutter von
drei kindern
[Musik]
ihr sohn bekommt 2018 die diagnose
computerspielsucht er wird süchtig nach
einem handy game lenny ist das jüngste
ihrer kinder genau wie seine zwei
schwestern bekommt er zum zehnten
geburtstag ein gebrauchtes smartphone
geschenkt schnell beginnt er ein
beliebtes handyspiel zu zocken und
bleibt hängen trotz strikter regeln
was uns halt aufgefallen war dass
plötzlich unser sohn sich verändert hat
vom verhalten vom wesen ist uns fremd
geworden er wurde schlecht gelaunt wenn
er nicht online war es auch schon mal
ausgerastet
ich habe den code ausgespäht wenn sie
den code eingegeben haben ich habe den
schlüssel ausgespäht wenn sie den tresor
öffnen wo mein handy da drin liegt und
wenn man dann keine mobilen daten hat
vom anderen handy mobile daten abzapfen
das game des lenny gespielt hat heißt
broll stars das ist bei kindern in
deutschland extrem beliebt seine mutter
hatte ihm damals erlaubt proll stars
herunterzuladen es ist eine ganz lustige
bunte cartoon optik und es wirkt relativ
harmlos aus heutiger perspektive
betrachtet was hätten sie vor drei
jahren gerne gewusst was sie eben
inzwischen wissen ich hätte sehr gerne
gewusst dass dieses spiel groß das was
wir ab sechs jahren im android app store
freigegeben ist glücksspiel ähnliche und
sucht machende mechanismen hat das
wusste ich nicht ich habe mich von
dieser niedlichen optik und von den
empfehlungen von anderen eltern oder
freunden habe ich mich einfach
falsch orientiert
was ulrike volpers damals ebenfalls
nicht wusste im kostenlosen spiel broll
stars kann man sich extras kaufen nanny
greift immer wieder zu
[Musik]
das war ein ganz schöner schock als die
rechnung kam und das waren ja auch so
summen von tatsächlich von 8 eur 23 euro
und das summierte sich aber alles dann
plötzlich dass der 80 euro waren dann
plötzlich summierte sich das auf 200
euro und über das halbjahr hinweg
sprechen wir hier von knapp 700 800 euro
die da aufgelaufen waren kinder mit zehn
sind noch nicht geschäftsfähig er konnte
trotzdem in app käufe tätigen weil die
standardmäßig so installiert sind wenn
man halt das gerät das smartphone nimmt
und sind die in-app-käufe aktiv die
eltern oder wer auch immer muss das
hingehen und deaktivieren das hatten
ulrike volpers und ihr mann versäumt wir
fragen zu den vorwürfen bei dem
finnischen computerspiel giganten super
sail nach das unternehmen vertreibt
allstars schriftlich heißt es wir
möchten dass alle unsere spieler ein
gesundes verhältnis zu unseren games
haben deshalb legen wir unsere spiele so
an dass sie davon abhalten übermäßig
lange zu spielen und dass sie keine
anreize schaffen online zu bleiben wir
fühlen uns verpflichtet eltern dabei zu
helfen eine rückerstattung zu bekommen
wenn ihre kinder ohne ihr einverständnis
geld in einem unserer spiele ausgegeben
haben soll
auch ulrike volpers bekam nach längerem
hin und her ihr geld zurück doch sie ist
überzeugt sie wusste damals zu wenig um
ihren sohn schützen zu können da kommt
erschwerend hinzu dass ich beobachte bei
uns aber auch im freundeskreis dass
viele eltern einfach digital erschöpft
sind es kommen ja ständig neue apps raus
und auch in berufen werden wir die ganze
digital gefordert aber nur wenn wir ein
paar digitale apps nutzen sind wir ja
nicht digital kompetent
was macht kinder wie lenny süchtig nach
handygames wir fragen einen insider der
selbst in der branche arbeitet wir
nennen ihn arthur er ist nur bereits
anonym über die praktiken der game
entwickler zu berichten wie schafft man
es denn erst mal die leute ans spiel zu
binden um sie dann im nächsten step zum
zahlenden nutzer umzuwandeln wie
funktioniert das spiele sollen ja ein
gewisses erfolgserlebnis beten das heißt
sie werden so gestaltet dass ich wenn
ich mich damit befasse wenn ich das
spiel spiele dann bekomme ich in
regelmäßigen abständen ein
erfolgserlebnis vom spiel präsentiert
und das hält mich letztendlich am
spielen
ab einem gewissen punkt werden diese
erfolgserlebnisse vom spieler
zurückgehalten dieses erfolgserlebnis
was ich vorher innerhalb von einer
minute bekommen hat auf das muss ich
dann auf einmal zwei wochen warten und
da ist natürlich dann der mechanismus
dar ok ich biete dir aber ein item an
was diese zeit drastisch verkürzt das
heißt ich kann dieses erfolgserlebnis
durch den kauf dieses alte muss sofort
wieder erleben
solche mechanismen in games die die
nutzer unterbewusst beeinflussen sollen
nennt man da klettern das können
ranglisten in games sein oder auch
spiele eigene währungen durch sie können
user den bezug zum geld verlieren das
sie ausgeben
diese daten können verschiedenster natur
sein aber unbewusst zwingen sie mich
einfach in ein spielverhalten oder
manipulieren mich in ein spielverhalten
was vielleicht eventuell schädlich für
mich ist oder was ich zum beispiel auch
gar nicht beabsichtige haben sie sich
die frage schon mal gestellt
ist das jetzt ein spiel was wirklich gut
ist für die leute ja die stelle ich mir
schon bei fast jeder entwicklung muss
ich sagen
und wie ist die antwort die antwort ist
schwierig würde ich sagen ich glaube es
gibt spiele die besser sind für leute
die leuten eine positive erfahrung
bringen können und es gibt halt sachen
wo ich sagen kann ok das überschreitet
irgendwo eine grenze
es sind ethisch moralische fragen wird
innerhalb der entwicklerstudios darüber
diskutiert
es wird halt sehr selten darüber
diskutiert ob das wirklich gut für die
leute ist sondern es wird ja in erster
linie gerade im free to play markt ist
das monetarisiert free to play ist halte
ein vertriebsmodell free to play ist
nicht die sein damit die leute nur spaß
an diesem spiel haben sondern free to
play ist so designt dass die leute
irgendwann dafür bezahlen
in berlin wird der verband der deutschen
games branche
wir sind verabredet mit dem
geschäftsführer felix falk
dass die weltgesundheitsorganisation die
exzessive nutzung von computerspielen
als eigenständige erkrankung anerkannt
hat findet der verband zitate nicht nur
falsch sondern auch gefährlich gesunde
kinder und jugendliche könnten
stigmatisiert werden
sind die spiele dann doch so angelegt
die kinder dann möglichst rein zu ziehen
ist das gefährlich für kinder auch
durchaus ich glaube es damals so
wahrscheinlich sein soll muss erst mal
anerkennen dass computer und videospiele
das für ganz viele kinder und
jugendliche aber auch für ganz viele
erwachsene das wichtigste medium sind
und das heißt natürlich auch dass bei
manchen und es zeigt noch studien dass
es nicht viele sind aber es sind einige
die die grenze zu ungesundem zu
ungesunder nutzung dann überschreiten
und die wenigen den muss man natürlich
gut helfen zeigt aber auch dass die
allermeisten das gut im griff haben aber
das heißt sie sagen diese mechanismen
sind per se erst mal unproblematisch
prinzipiell ist das was angeboten wird
ein mechanismen legitim und
gesetzeskonform und auch nicht
problematisch es sei denn es gibt
einzeln aus
einzelne anwendungen dieser mechanismen
wo man dann sagt da ist eine grenze
überschritten wir reden hier von
millionen von spielen natürlich sind das
schwarze schafe mit dabei gegen die
waren was machen muss mein eindruck ist
bislang dass eltern oft überfordert sind
also die sind digitalen nicht so fit wie
man eigentlich annehmen würde es wäre
natürlich schön wenn noch digital noch
fitter werden weil das wichtigste in der
medienkompetenz ist dass eltern mit
ihren kindern auf augenhöhe über das
medium sprechen und miteinander auch
regeln besprechen weil im gegensatz zu
china beispielsweise wo einfach der
staat sagt ich mache das interne aus-
oder an und entscheide das für den
bürger haben wir diese freiheit in
deutschland selber individuell und das
grundgesetz sagt das ist ein eltern
privileg zu entscheiden was machen meine
kinder in den eigenen vier wänden die
branche schiebt die verantwortung auch
auf die eltern und was macht die politik
der bundestag hat erst im frühjahr
2021 den jugendmedienschutz in
deutschland nachgebessert in deutschland
wurde bei der altersfreigabe von spielen
bislang vor allem darauf geachtet ob sie
zum beispiel gewaltdarstellungen
enthalten
erstmals sollen auch risiken wie
kaufanreize oder glücksspiel ähnliche
elemente in die bewertung der games mit
einfließen diese risiken sollen
berücksichtigt werden wenn und soweit
sie die alterseignung des mediums
wesentlich prägen
vielen fachleuten reicht das nicht aus
kristin schneider arbeitet als
sozialpädagogin mit computerspiel
süchtigen jugendlichen und ist im
vorstand des fachverband
medienabhängigkeit
sie fordert von der neuen
bundesregierung
computerspiele stärker zu regulieren
abhängigkeit spricht sich eindeutig
dafür aus auch dinge auch mechanismen in
computerspielen zum beispiel zu
verbieten kinder und jugendliche sollten
geschützt sein nichts völlig unbegrenzt
ein produkt nutzen zu können hier geld
ausgeben zu können gerade mit diesen
monetarisierung strategien ja auch so
funktionieren dass teilweise geldbeträge
verschleiert werden hier wird die
unwissenheit und naivität ja auch der
kinder ausgenutzt kinder benutzen diese
medien teilweise auch ohne rundum
aufsicht der eltern und das darf nicht
nur an eltern delegiert werden und es
darf auch nicht verschwiegen werden
sondern hier brauche es klare
gesetzliche regelungen
in mark warnecke fall ist auf seinem
umfeld lange nicht aufgefallen dass er
ein problem mit computerspielen hat
haben wir hier vielleicht auch so ein
gesellschaftliches problem das die
krankheit einfach viel nicht klar ist
definitiv
ich werde lieber leben darauf gekommen
dass es sowas gibt und dann sucht und
dann auch noch wie im computerspielen
zocken war für mich das normalste der
welt was auf jeden fall fehlt sind
selbsthilfegruppen für betroffene und
prävention das sind so diese beiden
sachen und eine selbsthilfegruppe hätte
mir damals vielleicht schon ein bisschen
geholfen deshalb hat er selbst eine
gegründet der bedarf sagt mike ist groß
[Musik]
verfügbare jugendliche überforderte
eltern und eine computerspielindustrie
die ständig neue ver führungen anbietet
es ist ein ungleicher kampf in denen
sich die politik stärker einmischen
sollte
[Musik]